hello and welcome my name is Mary Kay
Bates I'm an application scientist with
thermo Fisher
scientific and today I present
information on how the new thermo
scientific cell Locker system segregates
stem cells protecting from contamination
and enhancing the environmental
stability for their growth and
propagation this presentation will
include data showing how the cell locker
system works to prevent any microbial
contaminants from entering a cell locker
chamber and how stability is maintained
even when a neighboring cell lock or
chamber is opened because the cell
Locker is a new concept I'm going to
take a few minutes right at the
beginning to show you what the cell
locker is before showing you results
about how it works
we know that stem cells are less
resilient they're more fragile and
sensitive than immortalised cell lines
which have been growing in culture for
many decades we know that stem cells are
less resilient to contamination and
they're generally less resistant to
infection or to co-culture with
fast-growing microorganisms stem cells
require comparatively more manipulation
than traditional cell lines almost
always daily manipulation and handling
they require more care and that handling
puts the cells at risk of exposure to
contamination from the air and from
workers normal flora on a greater basis
than cell lines which may only require
handling every third day or so
also the growth media and reagents used
for culturing stem cells are simply more
expensive such that any contamination is
more costly when cells have to be
discarded in experiments repeated
and stem cells are less resilient more
sensitive to changing conditions they
are more reactive to any triggers which
could signal them to differentiate
because of their sensitivity most labs
recommend that stem cells be segregated
in a different incubator than other cell
types but we know this is not always
possible due to space limitation in the
lab or to limited funding to pay for
another cell culture incubator
the cell locker system is a novel
innovation which is designed into our
newest line of co2 incubators the
thermal scientific carousel BIOS and
thermo scientific for mastery cycle 160
litre incubators as shown here the
traditional incubator is subdivided into
six polycarbonate chambers which can
stay in the incubator or they can slide
out each cell actor has its own door but
the full inner incubator door can also
be open for cleaning the incubator
itself features a proven 12 log dry heat
sterilization cycle in chamber hepa
filtration and sensors and covered
protected water reservoir the entire
incubator chamber can also be optional
100 percent pure copper
each cell locker itself is made of the
same polycarbonate that makes up most
cell culture dishes and it contains an
optional transport door in case you want
to carry the cell Locker chamber out of
the incubator protecting yourselves from
the incubator all the way across to the
hood or down the hall to another lab the
cell lockers are autoclavable up to a
maximum of 12 times
both sides of each cell locker chamber
include an easily replaceable 0.2
micrometer membrane filter which permits
air circulation but prevents
transmission of particles into or out of
the cell lockers when the door is closed
so each cell locker is essentially a
small quarantine incubator for isolating
projects users or cell types
the cell locker system is easily
configured to fit the way your lab works
you can use it to segregate different
cell types users or experiments to
isolate and protect them from other work
for example if you previously had one
incubator that was only for induced
pluripotent stem cells now you can keep
these cells in the same incubator with
your other cell types with no worries
saving space in the lab and reducing the
number of incubator stacks you need to
gain access to yourself simply open the
outer heated incubator door and then
open the smaller individual inner door
for each cell locker
to give you an idea of the size each
cell locker chamber holds 9t 75 flasks
or up to 28 multi-well plates an
optional sliding work tray gives you
easy access to your flasks dishes or
plates
each chamber includes the optional
sliding work tray and that includes some
tip protection to protect your dishes
each cell Locker also includes the
optional transport door if you never
remove the cell lock or chamber from the
incubator you probably would not use the
transport door but if you want to carry
an individual cell lock or to your cell
culture hood or to a lab down the hall
the transport door would extend the
protection of the cell Locker
as you carry your cell culture vessels
so now you have a better understanding
of the cell locker system let me show
you why we invented the cell locker
system and some data from our extensive
testing to show how it will protect your
stem cells from contamination and
preserve their ideal culturing
environment
we know from our own surveys of more
than a thousand people globally that
about 87% of scientists culturing cells
experienced at least one contamination
event each year and many of us have more
than one event each year there are some
reasons for this but a big one is that
contamination comes from us humans carry
an average of 10,000 microorganisms per
square centimeter on our skin and from
those normal flora combined with
microorganisms in the environment even
in nor air carries between 30 and 1000
microorganisms per cubic meter
those are the most common cell culture
contaminant with up to 15% of cultures
in the United States contaminated up to
80% contamination in Japan and an
average of 35% contamination in Europe
and the rest of the world
we know that Michael plasma is caused
widespread effects because of their
ubiquity and their effects on cells they
are the most serious contaminant for
cultured cells
Mikell plasmas come from humans and from
other cultures technically michael
plasmas are bacteria but they are much
smaller than most bacteria and so they
can grow in your cultures to very high
densities without detection
also michael plasmas have no cell wall
so they are resistant to most
antibiotics which are directed against
the peptidoglycan in the bacterial cell
wall
Mikell plasmas affect the host cells
metabolism and may affect the morphology
they can cause chromosomal alterations
and damage the DNA and provokes
cytopathic responses in the cells all of
these alterations mean that your cells
will not respond normally in your
downstream assays the only way to know
for sure if your cells are carrying
mycoplasma is to test regularly
statistics show that the incidence of
mycoplasma is inversely proportional to
the amount of testing because if you
test you can detect a contamination and
limit the spread and the damage
so we thought about how much a
mycoplasma contamination could cost the
stem-cell lab of course this cost
estimate varies widely depending on the
lab itself how many people are involved
the time required to fight a
contamination the type and cost of the
stem cells and so on in short all these
costs are higher when working with stem
cells than with immortalised cell lines
and if the contamination spreads across
the lab those costs will rapidly
escalate for example one lab said they
spent as much as 100,000 u.s. dollars
fighting a mycoplasma outbreak
here I'm showing a more typical example
of costs to one stem-cell researcher who
spent one month dealing with a
mycoplasma contamination of her human
stem cells a new vial of cells cost
$1,000 u.s. and a mycoplasma
test kit cost $300 she figures she spent
more than two thousand dollars on
materials in reagents over that month
and her salary for one month is four
thousand US dollars and all her other
works stopped because all she could do
was work to eliminate this contamination
so you can see why we invented the cell
Locker to protect cells from
contamination
the cell locker chamber
prevents entry or exit of microorganisms
we wanted to ensure that we had a lot of
proof of this claim that microorganisms
could not pass through the filters which
protect the cell locker chambers so we
sent a cell locker system to two
independent test labs one at health
protection England important down in the
UK and one at IBF II in Germany all told
these independent labs performed over 15
rounds of testing with three very small
bacteria including Staphylococcus aureus
which is about 0.8 micrometers in size
breven demonise de minuto which is about
0.2 micrometers and is the accepted test
organism for testing 0.2 micrometer pore
size and finally mycoplasma
RL one of the most common cell culture
contaminants which ranges from 0.1 to
0.6 microns in size these companies and
labs circulated thousands of
microorganisms into the air circulation
of the incubator containing the cell
locker system for up to an hour at a
time
in all these tests not one bacterial
colony no growth at all was able to
enter or exit a closed cell locker but
hundreds of microorganisms were
collected inside the incubator but
outside the cell lockers in one other
type of test which I'm not showing here
these researchers took four individual
cell locker chambers out of the
incubator system and put them in a
bombardment cabinet one of these cell
lockers had a leaky door gasket and
another had the door propped open about
one centimeter in both of these
compromised cell lockers microorganisms
could get in through the air space
around the transport door but in the
properly closed cell lockers zero growth
was found inside together these tests
prove that the cell locker system and
the membrane filters protect cells
incubated inside from cross
contamination
so I know that we've all heard that when
filtering liquids with a 0.2 micrometer
membrane filter sometimes small
microorganisms like michael plasmas or
viruses could possibly slip through but
it turns out that when filtering air
complex membrane filters have an
effective ten times smaller diameter due
to the physical processes of impaction
interception and diffusion
this chart shows efficacy of four
different types of filters with
different structures and pore sizes I've
also added in relative sizes of some
microorganisms for comparison
PC filters shown in the green and purple
lines are polycarbonate filters with
smooth circular pores like we normally
think of when filtering liquids and you
can see that in the Purple Line 3 micron
pore sizes let a lot of smaller
particles through and 1 micron pores
shown shown in the green approach 100%
capture for particles of 0.5 micrometers
are larger
PTFE the blue line is a
polytetrafluoroethylene filter with a
more complex structure and with a three
micron pore size this type of filter is
nearly 100% effective even at really
small particles
we chose polyethersulfone or p/es
filters graphed in the red
also do not have straight through pores
but instead they have a complex fibrous
structure which presents a labyrinth for
particles trapping them and the p/es
0.2 micron filter we use captures 100
percent of the particles even down past
0.01 micrometers smaller than the
smallest viruses which are parvo viruses
and those are just about 0.02 microns in
size our PE s filters have also been
tested for cytotoxicity and biosafety
and they repel oils from skin together
all these factors combine to provide
assurance that no particles of any size
can enter a closed cell locker so your
stem cells are continuously protected
from contamination
so that's a lot on contamination now let
me talk about the environment for your
stem cells cells and culture of all
types are constantly sampling their
external environment
and the cells are continuously
responding to conditions and changes in
temperature atmosphere humidity
nutrients and stimulants or repressors
in the medium and of course proximity of
other cells and cell responses will
change depending on these cues so
variations in any of these can cause
varied cell responses in differential
gene or protein expression or whether
the cells enter the growth site growth
cycle whether they grow faster or slower
or they stay quiet so this is another
consideration we thought about in
designing the cell locker system we
wanted the cells to be in the most ideal
environment possible for the maximum
time possible
let me share with you what the co2
incubator provides and growing yourself
and how variation would affect the cells
first of course we think of temperature
the incubator is generally set to 37
degrees Celsius to mimic human or animal
body temperature we know that most cells
are generally okay for a few days at 4
degrees but higher temperatures are
detrimental to cells most cells cannot
withstand more than a few hours of
temperatures 2 degrees Celsius above
normal and for many cells even one
degree higher results in cell death at
the same time lower temperatures result
in slower cell growth cells may even
enter growth stasis
next carbon dioxide which many of us
know is provided to balance the growth
medium to a neutral pH but did you know
that the amount of co2 we use in the
incubator which is most often set at 5%
is dependent upon the amount of buffer
provided by the growth medium and 5% co2
equates to 40 millimeters of mercury
which is the amount of co2 pressure in
the venous blood of a human and in the
lungs as all cells produce co2 as a
waste byproduct of metabolism and
changes or fluctuation in co2
concentration can affect the cells
morphology and growth you may for
example see the membranes are not as
tightly attached or you may see granules
in the cytoplasm as an indicator of
toxicity
next relative humidity is provided by
the co2 incubator to prevent evaporation
of water from the growth medium only
water evaporates so that means that the
remaining salts minerals peptides etc
become more concentrated and as that
process continues those can reach toxic
concentrations and we know that
evaporation is four times faster at 80%
humidity then add humidity greater than
93 percent
finally oxygen many if not most people
working with stem cells culture them
under hypoxic conditions because the
oxygen concentration in the stem cell
niche is about one to six percent oxygen
very different than the air we breathe
which is 21% oxygen
we know that when stem cells are grown
in oxygen concentration that mimics the
stem cell niche they grow faster show
less damage to DNA from reactive oxygen
species including for example
chromosomal fusions double strand breaks
and die Center chromosomes most
importantly cells cultured in low oxygen
show normal gene expression
with that understanding of how the
incubator conditions effects themselves
let's look at what happens in the cell
locker system compared to a normal
incubator closed cell lockers do not
experience it when you open a neighbor
neighboring cell locker so here is shown
the environmental conditions in a
typical laboratory room temperature is
20 to 22 degrees Celsius with
atmospheric carbon dioxide concentration
of 0.04 percent and 30 to 60 percent
relative humidity is typical of an
indoor room and then 21% oxygen in the
Earth's atmosphere
now in our newer hair cell Vios
incubator typical incubator settings
would be 37 degrees Celsius 5% co2 93
percent relative humidity or higher and
let's say 1% oxygen but when you open
any incubator door the conditions inside
rush out to mix with the lab air and in
this incubator we see that the incubator
temperature drops to about 30 degrees
co2 drops to below one percent relative
humidity to below 30 percent and oxygen
goes up to 19 to 21 percent all of these
conditions will be reestablished to the
incubator setting in 10 minutes or so
following a 30 second door opening and
in most incubators recovery is actually
much slower than this for sensitive
cells such as stem cells that door
opening can be very disruptive to their
growth and of course this effect is
multiplied every time you open the
incubator door so if you are sharing an
incubator with others because you don't
have space or funding for multiple
incubators you can see how yourself may
not spend much time at all during the
day at their ideal conditions
now let's look at what happens in the
cell locker system when you open one of
the six cell lockers the closed cell
lockers maintain 37 degrees 5% co2 93
percent humidity and oxygen remains very
low
let me show you in a graphic form that
when you open one cell lock or chamber
the remaining side shaped five chambers
maintain the ideal growth environment
here I'm showing the recovery when
opening one cell locker for thirty
seconds a very long door opening you can
see that the temperature drops and
rapidly recovers to 37 degrees
a similar fast recovery happens for
relative humidity in co2
oxygen in the open cell Locker rises
rapidly from 1% to 21% and then rapidly
drops back down to 1%
now let me add in the conditions in the
cell lockers which were not opened you
can see that it's just a stable flat
line for temperature relative humidity
and co2
the oxygen shows a slight bump of one to
two percent above 1% but this is much
better than rising all the way to 21% we
wanted to show an extreme example of
culturing at 1% oxygen but most of you
are probably culturing it 3 to 5% oxygen
and would not see much of a change at
all for sensitive stem cells this
provides a much more stable environment
than culturing in a standard incubator
and for oxygen we know that oxygen
affects nearly every cellular process so
this is really critical for proper stem
cell growth
another big benefit of the cell locker
system is that it reduces gas use and
evaporation by at least 50 percent
depending on the conditions required
compared to the same incubator design
that does not incorporate the cell
lockers
so first let me show you data for gas
use we looked at nitrogen saving in a
hypoxic incubator because keeping oxygen
at one to six percent instead of
atmospheric 21% uses a lot of injected
nitrogen gas if you never open any of
the doors from the cell locker system as
shown in the first line in this table
then the cell locker system uses
slightly more gas because all of those
gaskets around the individual doors let
a little gas through but in a more
realistic scenario where you are opening
the doors throughout the day you can see
that depending on the number of openings
and the oxygen concentration you would
use at least 50% less gas
so if we look at the most common example
for six thirty second door openings
using three percent oxygen this scenario
the cell locker system uses 60% less
nitrogen so for a typical lab this tank
of nitrogen would last 14 days instead
of five point seven days a significant
savings
now let's look at evaporation we tested
evaporation using 15 grams of water in
three dishes each in all six cell
lockers and found an average evaporation
rate of 0.6 grams of water loss per day
and you can see that it's very uniform
across all of the cell lockers that
evaporation rate compares to our
standard Harris cell vios incubator
which itself has very low evaporation
with a rate of 1.3 grams of water loss
per day so if you are using a lot of
96-well and 384-well screening assays
and you struggle with edge effect or
drying this cell our system savings of
more than 50% reduction in evaporation
is a benefit to you and using 50% less
carbon dioxide or nitrogen gas is a
benefit to everyone
now we did have a few labs do beta
testing on the cell locker system for us
and one of those labs works with induced
pluripotent stem cells they had worked
very hard to optimize their system and
they work in a GMP cleanroom so
everything is carefully documented
making them an ideal beta tester they
tested the cell locker system side by
side with their optimized incubator
producing and growing IPS cells they
found that their IPS cells showed the
same quality when cultured in the cell
locker system compared to the optimized
incubator in both cases they tested and
compared more than 50 colonies finding
zero spots of differentiation in either
case
next they harvested cryopreserved each
cell from each system when they thawed
and regrew the cells in their optimized
system and in the cell locker system
they found that the IPS cell colonies
showed the same quality
taken together this work shows that the
materials and environmental conditions
in the cell locker system can right out
of the box provide the ideal conditions
obtained after a lot of time and
investment in a carefully designed eight
system so much less time an empirical
optimization would be required when
bringing a cell locker system into a lab
in summary I hope I have shown you that
there are great reasons to use the cell
locker system to grow your stem cells
including protection from contamination
preservation of the ideal growth
environment and reduce gas use in
evaporation the cell locker system is
patented and available exclusively in
hair cell bios and for most areas stereo
cycle co2 incubators thank you very much
for your attention and I wish you the
very best success in your work